(soft music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical.
Bipedal, naked, large brain,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made
possible by the generosity
of humans like you.
(soft jingle)
(soft music)
- Okay, well it's a
great honor to be here,
and I thank the organizers, Nick and Ajit,
for inviting me and also
all of you for coming.
So, I would like to start
by showing you a video clip
of something that we filmed last summer
in Gorongosa National Park in Mozambique.
So, Gorongosa is an amazing
bi-diversity hotspot,
and we have here what looks like a fairly
kind of peaceful scene.
So we have a troop of
baboons resting and feeding.
We've got some warthogs walking around.
We've got some waterbuck
grazing and so on.
So it's all quite idyllic.
But of course, nature's rarely idyllic.
And if you look more
closely, you can see that
this guy here in the middle is quite
busy doing something.
And then if we zoom in,
which we will in a second,
we'll see that he has hunted and is now
eating a young antelope, a reedbuck.
But unlike a lion with a killer bite,
this baboon is eating the
antelope while it's still alive,
which you could argue is
not particularly sensible,
given that it means that the antelope
still has a chance to
escape, which as you'll see
in a second, it's still very much
trying to do at this point.
So for us, I think this really is quite a,
sort of gruesome scene,
but at the same time,
it does raise some very
interesting questions
that we can ask about
what might be going on
in that baboon's head.
And some of those
questions actually go back
to what Nick was talking
about in his introduction.
So for example, does this baboon know
that the antelope is still alive?
Does the baboon know
that the fact that the
antelope is moving is a
sign that it's still alive?
Does the baboon know that
it can kill the antelope,
and does it know what it needs
to do to kill the antelope
and that, once it has
killed it, the antelope
will remain dead?
Does the baboon know that
it itself will die one day,
and so will all other
baboons and all other
antelopes and so on?
And then finally, you might
have noticed in that video,
the antelope's mother
standing to one side.
So another question could be, I think,
will the antelope's mother
grieve for her calf?
So, I can't promise to be able to answer
most or even any of these questions,
but what I will try to do in this talk
is to first survey what kinds of responses
have been recorded among non-human animals
to dead individuals,
and what these responses
might tell us about the kind of underlying
death-related concepts in these animals.
And then at the end, I
will also briefly consider
grief specifically, as
well as what implications
a better understanding of these phenomena
might have for animal welfare.
So, on this graphical
summary, what I tried to do
was to put together,
to give you an idea, basically,
of the orders of mammals.
So, the taxonomic orders of mammals,
from which we have
published scientific reports
on responses to death.
And I think one of the
things that quickly pops out
is that these reports cover quite a broad
taxonomic spread, although
some of the orders
are represented by just
one or a few species.
And that, of course, doesn't mean that
mammals and other orders
don't respond to the dead.
It's just that we don't
have, yet have good,
kind of published reports on them.
So, for example, we don't really know
a great deal about how bats or aardvarks
or kangaroos respond to the dead.
Although, for at least
some of these kind of
missing pieces, we do have
some anecdotal evidence
that that exists, just not
scientifically published yet.
So we'll come back to this figure later
when we look at what
specific ways there are
of animal's responses
or animal's treatment
of the dead.
But first, what I want
to do now is to quickly
tell you about three
chimpanzee case reports
that we observed at our
field research site,
which was coordinated by Kyoto University,
and which is located in
Bossou in Guinea, West Africa.
And they're each kind of incredibly
striking cases, I think.
Things you see, you
know, once you see them,
you don't easily forget them.
All three cases involved
young individuals,
young infants, so Jokro, Jimato, and Veve,
each of whom died of a
suspected respiratory illness
before they turned three years old.
And these dead infants,
they weren't abandoned
by their mothers, but they
continued to be carried
and to be looked after, to
be groomed and protected,
much like live animals
of this age would be
by their mothers.
And over the course of the
carrying, all three infants
mummified, and the length of the carrying
was really extraordinary.
So in the first case, carrying continued
for more than 27 days.
In the second case, for 68 days,
and then in the third case, for 19 days.
And it's extraordinary for many reasons,
but one of the reasons is
that this length of carrying,
really amazing because the, you know,
the infants have to be
carried in ways that
no live infant ever is,
because they, you know,
they could no longer hold onto the mother
and they could no longer
cling, so they really
encumbered the mothers.
They had to be carried in unusual ways.
So for example, between,
sorry, by grasping
a limb between the neck and the shoulder,
which is what you see
in these images here,
when the mothers were
walking, or by climbing
and then, sorry, when
climbing, holding the body
between the thigh and
the belly, the so-called
thigh pocket in the chimpanzee,
that's what you see in this image.
Or even by dangling, just by the foot when
resting in the trees.
And the mothers also
continued to groom the bodies
and they swatted flies from them.
You're seeing that in that video.
And the grooming in
particular, I think you can
interpret in different ways, I guess.
So you could, for example,
argue that the mothers,
these mothers don't know
that their infants are dead,
and they continue to treat them as alive,
or that they do know that
the infants are not alive,
but they choose to keep them clean anyway.
And then group-mates other than the mother
also showed a lot of interest in the body.
So, we saw a number of different responses
from these individuals.
They ranged from investigatory behaviors,
like smelling and touching and inspecting,
or lifting limbs and dropping them,
to dragging and pulling and
playing with the corpses.
But also, to care-taking and attendance.
So this, for example,
here is the, is this,
that infant's grandmother,
who sat by the corpse
while the mother was off feeding,
and she groomed it and
she swatted flies from it.
And the mothers were
generally quite tolerant
to these behaviors, even if it meant
relinquishing possession
of the corpses temporarily.
So you see this one
particular mother here,
and there's the corpse left behind.
And this is a juvenile that
comes in quite cautiously,
picks up the corpse, and carries it off.
And you see the mother
initially, she turns around,
she sort of gets up as
if she was making to go
to get the corpse back, but eventually,
she just sort of lets the
juvenile run off with it and play.
And again, this is not too dissimilar to
what a live infant of this
age would be allowed to do.
Two year old's do still
travel with the mother
at all times, but when
the group is stationary,
the mothers do allow these
infants to wander off
and play with others in the group.
And then interestingly,
or maybe importantly,
we never saw any aggression being directed
towards the corpses, although in one case,
this is the one case
when an adult male used
one of these bodies in a
display during a fight.
So this was at the point when the body had
already completely mummified.
But even here, I think this seemed like
rather kind of gentle
handling of the corpse.
He's not tearing it to pieces.
He's not sort of flinging it around.
But actually, sort of quite softly,
just pulls it along the ground and then
gently switches hands when,
when he turns around.
And just lastly, I want to show a clip
that illustrates a kind of combination
of different responses.
So, here first of all, we've got an infant
playing with a corpse.
And I think he's sort of veering between
fear and curiosity, really.
Until it seems like curiosity
gets the better of him.
And so, this is the dead infant's mother,
and this is the live,
so this infant's mother.
And if you watch
carefully, you'll see that
that live infant's mother is also peering
at the body with curiosity, but then she,
in a moment, she'll
show what might be seen
as a sort of aversion to the corpse.
So, watch this.
So, she doesn't really,
you know, she's happy
for her infant to play with the corpse,
but she really doesn't
want to be touched by it.
So, you know, having said
that, this was really
the only time when we saw any individual
respond in this way.
So, so far I've talked
about dead infant care
in chimpanzees, but this is something that
is seen very broadly among primates.
We have examples, for
example, from geladas,
mountain gorillas, orangutans, lemurs,
and some of it on a really huge scale.
Sugiyama and his colleagues, for example,
documented over 150 cases
of dead infant carrying
over 24 years of observation
on Japanese macaques.
And in each case, really,
the theme is the same.
The mothers continue to
show maternal behavior
toward their dead infants.
And furthermore, the behavior
isn't restricted to primates.
So, other mammals have
been seen to care for
and to transport dead infants.
So, dolphins and whales, for
example, carry dead calves.
Dingos and elephants stay
with their deceased young.
Or this giraffe here from
Fred Bercovitch's observations
remains with and is sort of nudging her
dead calf in this picture.
So, and behavior itself
is generally explained
in terms of their persistence of this
extremely strong mother
infant bond in these species.
It's particularly strong in mammals,
where the mother really
invests a huge amount
into each of her off-spring.
And then if we also add
in non-infant deaths,
so other individuals, there too, we have
some of the same responses
that we saw for infants,
of care-taking, like
grooming, the inspection
and attendance by the body, but also,
things that indicate maybe more negative
or sort of conflicted
psychological states,
such as alarm calling or aggression
and even cannibalism and
sexual behavior, in some cases.
And I think there are
also more, kind of nuanced
response classes as well, but the majority
really do, the majority which are reported
in this large collection of papers,
which I'm going to make use of next,
can be classed into one or other of these
kind of broad categories.
So then on the next
slide, I'm going to try to
show you graphically how
these different responses
are distributed among the
main orders in species
that we saw at the beginning.
So for example, in
chimpanzees, other authors
have reported aggression towards corpses,
including those of infants,
and even cannibalism.
And then in other species as well,
we see quite a, sort of broad spectrum of
responses from care-taking
to sexual behavior.
But I should say that, so
some of these descriptions,
I think, are more complete than others.
And obviously for some
orders, we have information
on the treatment only of dead infants,
but not of dead adults, or vice versa.
So I think this is maybe
best seen as really
just a snapshot of our current knowledge.
Very much just an emerging picture.
But it does mean that,
I think, we can say that
at least these responses are present
in these different orders and species.
So then the important
question of what drives
these different responses?
What might determine when
individuals respond with
care-taking and when
with aggression or alarm?
And several people here have
discussed interesting potential ideas.
So for example, a death
where the cause is clear,
so let's say, a predator
attack, may lead to less, say,
alarm calling than a case
where the cause is unclear,
so like, an opaque illness, for example.
Then, state of decomposition.
So how much like a live
animal the corpse looks.
It may be that less
decomposed corpses elicit
more, kind of, normal
or stronger reactions.
Then the diseased social,
the diseased social status,
so an alpha male, a dead
alpha male would generate
more interest than a
more peripheral male or
an infant that's not yet socially,
fully socially integrated.
Also, the diseased social
relationship to the,
to the individual.
So a mother will respond,
probably will respond
differently to her own
dead off-spring than to
an unrelated group-mate.
Also, Christophe Boesch
interestingly suggested,
groups that live in
high prediction habitats
have more frequent encounters with,
and therefore, a more
kind of sophisticated
knowledge of death, while
a sort of similar vein,
Katie Cronin's team
suggested a chimpanzee mother
with a dead infant is actively seeking
sensory information on the
corpse, which may inform
her future behavior, should another one of
her infants die.
So, we might be seeing
not only these kinds of
proximate body cue and
relationship quality effect,
but also, learning about
death in determining
what responses we see.
But perhaps there's also
a slightly different way
of looking at this, if we
wanted to split things up
by sort of underlying
psychological states.
So there are some reactions
that might fall under
sort of normal interactions,
and those might suggest
that there's a lack of understanding that
the state of that individual has changed.
Although, I think even
that's not entirely clear
in all cases, but at some
point, we begin to see
behaviors that suggest
that such recognition
has indeed taken place.
And I think stemming
from this recognition,
we may find things like curiosity,
curious exploration of the
body, and we may find fear,
so fearful responses like alarm calling.
But essentially, I think that
what we might be seeing is
that at the intersection
of these things, is a
recognition by the individual
that something's not right.
So, even though this
corpse may look normal,
it doesn't act normal when
I try to play with it.
It doesn't join in when I hit it.
It doesn't respond.
So in a way, the corpse
violates expectations,
as Andre Consales calls
it, to which you might
respond with curiosity or
fear, or some combination
of these two.
But if that is the case,
then this can in turn
tell us about what those expectations are
that non-human animals have.
And that comes back to those questions
that I raised at the very
beginning for the baboon.
Do they know the
difference between animate
and inanimate things?
What cues do they use
to tell the difference
between things that are alive
and things that aren't alive?
And so on.
And of course, these are some of the
exact same questions that
developmental psychologists
are asking in studying
children's understanding
of animacy and death,
and it also links to the
motivation behind comparative thanatology,
this recently emerged field, that seeks
evolutionary roots to death-related
behavioral and psychological phenomena.
So the idea is that by using information
from species that are
both closely and distantly
related to humans, we can gain insight
into the evolutionary
origins of our own responses
to the dead.
So and then, returning to grief, although,
I think the adaptive value
of grief is unclear to us.
In other words, it's not entirely clear
what the function of grief is.
It could be a signal to
attract support from others,
or simply, it could be
just a byproduct of,
of the processes that
maintain those strong
social bonds in the first place.
And they linger even once that individual
has passed away, one of the
individuals has passed away.
But having said that, there
are, among non-humans,
excuse me, quantifiable,
behavioral and hormonal responses
that accompany the loss of an individual
with a close social bond,
so we see loss of appetite,
loss of sleep, withdrawal
from the social group,
things like lethargy, and
even elevated stress hormones.
And so, given all of
this, I think I agree with
Barbara King's perspective
here that it's possible
to decouple grief from
the awareness of death.
So, you don't have to know what death is
in order to be able to grieve.
And then finally, that brings us to this
last point, which is that managing grief
is something that we perhaps
ought to bear in mind
explicitly when devising management plans
for dying zoo individuals or even pets.
So in zoos, dying animals
are often separated
from their normal social
groups, and pets that are
about to be euthanized,
they're also separated
from their companions.
But this can lead to extended periods of
searching and distress in those companions
that get left behind, so
alternative to these practices
might be seen as more humane.
So this here is the chimpanzee, Pansy,
who was allowed to die in the company
of her social group at a Scottish zoo.
Jim Anderson and
colleagues who have studied
that particular case argue
that, that this allowed
those others in the group
that remain behind to
get a sense of the fact
that Pansy wasn't coming back.
So, if we consider the
welfare of the animals
that stay behind, then
I think it may be better
to allow death not to happen
kind of removed in space
and out of sight, but
actually in the presence
of the others with whom that individual
shares a close social bond.
And that might prevent extended distress
in these close affiliates
and also, allow animals
to learn about the dying process and about
the finality of death.
Thank you very much.
(clapping)
(soft music)